about the course.
The time is now.
We would prefer not to take up these type
of topics during the class.
So I would request anybody who's got any
issues, any problems,
if you bring me an e-mail and you
expected to reply.
Everything should be taken up here just
now.
Thank you. Great. It's nice.
This Radhakrishna's birthday is a great
day.
Is.
Yeah.
Okay.
Stop the team PPT share and share the
entire screen.
Visible in the recording. OK, now this is.
..
going to be a cumbersome task.
DHRUV,
can you give me a screenshot as to how it
appears on your screen?
Just now.
Yeah, I could probably...
I don't know whether there is any way
where you can see it on a full screen.
If I take it on a full screen,
I will not be able to see these lovely
things that you are writing on the side.
Okay.
Totally based on batch dashboard which we
have built for. This is SAURAV LAHIRI.
If my assignment is totally based on a
dashboard which we are building for
monitoring of batches,
I don't know the background of the type
of work you do.
You'll have to mention what these batches
are. How can the connection and...
Connector diagram be built as something
you'll have to figure out.
YouTube.
We have to understand your application
detail if I have to attempt to do the
assignment.
I wouldn't know really what your batches
are, what you monitor, how you monitor,
what are the sub-modules you've got for
monitoring,
what type of monitoring you do,
whether you're monitoring the CPU usage
or you're monitoring the RAM usage,
disk usage, network usage.
whether you're monitoring the performance
of the batch on some other parameters,
what modules you've worked for doing that,
whether they run synchronous with your
dashboard or they run asynchronously.
And I think I've answered your question.
Yes.
DHRUV,
I'm waiting for you to share your
screenshot.
I want to see your full screen as to how
it appears.
Well,
this is sad if this is the type of screen
you are getting.
You only see me.
That means you the slide doesn't appear
on your slide. Who's shared this?
Ruth,
could you share the screen what you're
getting at present?
Okay, I'm just...
Switching on the mic so that DHRUV can
speak.
Hi, sir, this guru here.
Hi, DHRUV.
I have a question in mind. It's not Dru,
it's GURURAJ for another.
Okay, ohh, good, right?
Regarding the assignment,
can that assignment be based on a feature
enhancement or it has to be always a
full-fledged application?
Because in feature enhancements also,
we will have modules and some.
See.
If you have a feature enhancement,
you have to give the architecture of your
original application.
If it is not available to you,
Yeah.
you have to do an exercise in
architecture reconstruction. Now,
the architecture reconstruction are not a
part of your assignment,
so you can assume that you have...
determine the architecture and present it.
So if you're doing feature enhancement,
you're going beyond the assignment.
Your assignment is just to present the
architecture of what you're going to
enhance. Okay,
the feature enhancement that you do is
going one step beyond the assignment for
Mm.
which you will not be rewarded.
What I was asking is the feature
enhancement itself,
where we have to apply.
That's not an architecture. No,
that is a change in the architecture.
To do a feature enhancement,
either it's a minor enhancement which
does not require the architecture to be
changed,
or it requires architectural change.
If it's architectural change,
it's a big assignment.
It's not the assignment which we are
giving you.
And if you're doing a feature enhancement
which requires architectural change,
you have to present the previous
architecture,
the reason why you are changing the
architecture,
what additional benefits you'll get,
and the new architecture,
which is far beyond what you've been
asked to do.
If you just do the first 30% of that
assignment, your job is done. See,
If you're doing a feature enhancement,
you have to present the current
architecture.
The moment you have presented the current
architecture, your project,
your assignment one is over.
Okay.
Isn't it? So 30% of what you plan to do,
you do and submit it. And...
Yes.
Actually, here, what happens,
so the individual feature,
Yeah.
what we are developing,
it it itself considered as a separate
Okay, okay,
then then then go call it an enhancement
thing, and...
architecture of a feature,
but then don't fit it up with the overall
architecture.
Treat this as a product in itself.
Okay.
Call that feature a product and present
the architecture of that.
feature as a product.
And it is used with the main application
Okay.
In short.
through its interoperability capability.
It is capable of operating with your main
application. God knows,
Yeah.
you might be able to operate it with
others also. God knows,
I don't know what you're talking about,
but maybe you're writing a feature which
Yes.
can be used in conjunction with a large
number of similar applications in the
market,
or it is interoperable only with a
particular application.
application you've got,
that's perfectly noted.
Then you don't require interoperability
generally as a feature,
but you require a very specific
interoperability. Okay,
then this feature is the application.
Talk.
Yes.
Don't call it a feature enhancement.
The moment you call it an enhancement,
then the old architecture comes into play.
Okay, okay.
Then you have to give you a reasoning for
enhancement.
What is the performance benefit you are
getting?
And then it goes beyond what is expected
from you. OK.
Uh.
URMILA only,
you have given me a screenshot from your
mobile phone. Yeah,
I can assure you if you are in the same
camp as DHRUV and you are trying to read
the slides from a mobile phone.
I would request you to somehow steal a
tablet from somebody at least.
So, Archan, yes. Now,
Renuka has given a screenshot. Renuka,
is there any way that you can close your
right hand side?
The right-hand side panel,
I can on my terminal,
I can close the right-hand side panel,
try closing.
Uh, yes, sir.
close it, your screen will become bigger.
Now,
rather than ask me to close my screen so
that I can't see the dialogue with my
students,
I would request you to close your
right-hand side screen so that you can
see it larger.
OK, now, although DHRUV,
after giving his comment,
has chosen to be silent.
I'll mention a few advantages of making
the presentation through Teams, vis-a-vis,
doing it on my PC and sharing my
PowerPoint with you.
The difference is that here you are being
able to go back and forth on this slide.
It's interactive. Number 2,
I get to see everything about Teams as a
teacher that I need to see while making
my presentation. I see your names,
I see the thing. And...
Maybe I have specs, I can see it clearly,
but I'm on a laptop, I'm not on a mobile,
let me be honest with you.
So on a laptop. Next is there,
there's something which you have not
mentioned just now,
but people have mentioned in the past
that when I use the Ms.
TEAMS channel and with my,
where my files get shared automatically
on SharePoint, see, I don't share it.
The moment I start presenting.
a copy goes into SharePoint and it
becomes available on Ms. TEAMS.
So that's an advantage.
I don't forget to share.
But the disadvantage is my annotations
don't come there.
My request to students has been in the
past that you want to see the annotations,
just go to the appropriate part of the
video.
So the annotations will make more sense
because I probably don't,
what I want as a permanent part of the
slide is already typed into the slide.
And what I scribble when I teach is not
really something that is a part of
content. It's just my way of
Keeping you occupied.
Okay.
Okay, view focus on content. Okay,
thank you. Yeah,
that was a nice way to put it. SATPRIT,
thanks for that.
Let me also try view.
Focus on content. Oh, fantastic. Yeah.
And then I close this sidebar also.
I've got it on the entire screen. Great.
But, DHRUV, you can say hello and agree,
disagree, or...
Say something.
Preferably,
I would like to hear your voice.
Drew, DHIMAN, are you there?
Yeah, SATPRIT, let me be honest with you.
I didn't know this option either.
I used to close the...
meeting chat on the side and things like
that. This is superb.
I've tried it just now and it gives you a
full screen view. Yeah, thanks.
Jasmine.
Thanks so much.
If you know some way to make sure the
annotation starts appearing on the slides,
you can share that also.
When I'm annotating the sites,
they don't get recorded on the SharePoint
copy.
Sure, so I will look and update it.
Is it?
Yeah, yeah, great. Okay,
so let's move forward. Assignments.
EC2 syllabus will be.
PRAJJWAL, is that an announcement? Oh, oh,
it's a question. You're asking right. Now,
what made you believe it would be till
CS6?
I would like to know the source of your...
Information,
because I need to correct that.
PRAJJWAL, where did you get this till CS6?
Hi, sir, good morning.
I did not get it from when you were just
Good morning.
recalling you mentioning that.
It's just your guest.
If it would be CS6 or 608, I was not sure,
so I just I just to ask you.
No, that's alright,
but where did the doubt emanate from?
I am very sorry, sir.
I just cannot recall it.
Some other?
Okay, fine.
Some other faculty may have announced in
their classes at maybe,
but our course handout very clearly says
Maybe, yeah.
CS8.
And if there's a mistake in the course
handout,
I'd like to correct it because that's
going to cause a lot of misunderstanding.
That's why I asked.
Because sometimes there are typographic
errors in the course handout.
Focus.
I'd like to be very careful on that.
And unless somebody asked me the course
for the comprehensive,
let me tell now itself,
it is right from CS1 to CS16. Okay.
Yes, yeah.
And why I emphasize this,
many people believe that the course is
only from CS9 to 16.
The fact is that if you want to answer
any question relating to 9 to 16,
You have to do one to it.
The fundamentals are covered at this end.
So any of these things will be required
to answer a question relating to 9 to 16.
For example,
these little tactics you can't live
without.
Okay, so anyway, thanks for asking.
It clarifies to everybody is to CS8.
And let me tell you very clearly all the
problems that you face regarding
uploading your...
assignment one tomorrow and day after are
not going to be attended to.
So don't be under any delusion that if
you have an internet problem on the 7th,
is going to be attended to you to by
support.
Support will forward to me and I won't
even read the mail.
I made it very clear right from the
beginning.
that you have to take it up in the
beginning of the contact session.
number six or seven,
so that I may be able to address any
problems. Invariably,
there are people who try to upload at
1159 at night on the 7th,
and then they'll say there was a network
error.
There's another problem I found to you
all are very busy people,
hard pressed for time.
There are people who land up at the last
moment
Uploading the wrong.
Assignment for the wrong course.
I cannot help you correct it.
I do not have the infrastructure and the
manpower to get into Taxila and try to do
the maneuvering.
So this is something which is difficult.
Next is the people, maybe it's a strategy,
I don't know, it's a mistake.
They say that, oh, I had, by mistake,
uploaded the incomplete assignment.
The complete assignment is available to
me. I'm sending it to you by e-mail.
And they do it two days later.
No, that doesn't work.
You can't take a medicine two days late.
You might be dead by then.
So all these sort of things don't work.
So then people say,
shouldn't there be a makeup for the
assignment? The makeup is all the six,
seven days that you've been provided,
right from the first day up till
The 7th, every day is a makeup.
You could well upload on the very first
day. At least midway through the dates.
One should have finished up uploading.
Anyway.
Some people take a risk.
Every risk has got a return.
Assignment submission in the form of PDF.
Yeah, copy of PPT, correct.
We take the PPT,
convert to PDF and upload it.
The reason we don't accept.
During engineering,
I have become more wise. Okay. Yeah,
there are lots of assignments that come
delivered by ChatGPT and Gemini these
days.
So if your assignment looks too plastic,
you get plastic marks.
So try to put some life into your
assignment.
Try to make it look non-Gemini.
Even if you use Gemini, you, after all,
it's absolutely fair to use Gemini,
ChatGPT, Claudius, whatever, Claude,
whatever you may be using.
But...
Make it your own before you submit it.
Yep.
Well, PRAJJWAL,
we've all gone through the same stuff.
I have submitted enough.
I've gone running to the faculty's
chamber as the last moment.
Someone managed to put it on his table
before the deadline.
And so then the deadline sometimes are
almost like falling dead.
And then you are just a little bit late
and he's locking his room and you give a
nice smile and say, sir, please.
Those are the paper days.
We didn't have online submission.
These portals like Taxila,
the faculty is fast asleep and the gates
of the portal close at 1159.
And if you're half uploaded also,
you get thrown out. So.
Technology has changed, their advantages,
their disadvantages, whatever it is. Okay.
Today, we'll be looking at 2 concepts.
LIRS architecture. Actually,
LIRS belongs to the second-half of the
course,
but since it is there in the first half,
it's even a part of the course for the
examination.
The idea has been put forth because there
are too many things happening in layers
these days and one example of an
architectural style.
was considered worth presenting in the
first half.
This a typical layer architecture.
You have the user.
who interacts with the presentation layer.
The user is not supposed to be allowed to
interact with any layer.
I believe tonight, yeah, true.
Okay, good.
So the user can only interact with the
presentation there. It's very tempting.
And particularly in small setups,
single person assignments,
you want to access data from the database,
you simply write the query directly into
the presentation layer. Disastrous.
Bad for design, bad for security,
bad in everywhere.
If you've done enough work,
and you're working in a streamlined
environment,
you probably won't even know that it is
possible.
So,
the presentation layer can only interact
with the business layer.
The business layer handles all the
processing logic.
The presentation layer should only handle
the powder and lipstick.
It just should be the face of the
application.
It should be able to pick up things and
just present it and in as beautiful a way
as possible, as user-friendly as possible,
but should not do an iota of thinking.
Leave the thinking to the business layer.
Any amount of thinking.
even the most fundamental thoughts,
adding two numbers.
Give it to the business layer.
Let the business layer present the
figures,
give the figure to the presentation layer,
let the presentation layer only present
it.
Even if adding two numbers has been taken
care of in the presentation layer,
that can be a recipe for disaster.
Because, tomorrow?
As a business,
you want to add the total in some other
way, God knows why.
Then the presentation layer has not
changed, so it shows the whole total.
So, that's not to be done,
then the business layer.
Speaks to the data layer.
or sometimes we call it the data access
layer.
which is the layer which accesses the
database.
So the database is completely isolated
from the business layer.
The business is also not taking direct
control of the data source.
The beauty here is that not only it
accesses the data layers that you have
created yourself,
it also interacts with any external APIs,
external systems.
External systems may be outside the
company and maybe within the company.
So, whichever rate may be,
the is the business news responsibility.
VISHAL.
Besides the data source,
you may also have some services.
These services could be background
services.
They are running in the background.
If you're using an Android application,
you will realize it very well.
There's a service for downloading.
You just tell the service to start
downloading it, as downloading it,
once downloading it,
informs the data layer. OK, fine,
I finished my job.
which informs the business layer,
informs the presentation layer,
the presentation layer knows that, okay,
download is complete.
Now I can ask for it to be shown.
So this could be a messaging service.
You give it to the messaging service,
the messaging service sends out an SMS or
a WhatsApp message or an e-mail or just
copies it into another app for storage
into Google Drive, OneDrive.
Dropbox, whatever.
So this gives you a sketchy idea.
What do you notice here?
Each layer uses the layer just below it.
That could be sideways use. Okay.
That's acceptable.
Another thing to remember about any of
these patterns,
these are architectural patterns.
They're not.
Gospel truths,
they have not been written about in
Mahabharata or Ramayana or the Granth Sai.
These are not that type of truths.
These are models.
These are conceptual models.
which align with your brain and help you
to think clearly.
And a model which is supposed to help you
to think clearly cannot be rigid.
When you alley the model.
You can apply any degree of flexibility.
You can make exceptions.
And if you study real-life models,
you will find exceptions to the rule.
You'll find things are done differently,
and with good reason,
by people who understand the subject.
Take a look.
This is a judiciary system.
Present Liam,
presentation Liam may have different
screens. Case creation screen.
judgment screen.
There'll be a lot of judges and court
staff connected over the land.
You may have a lot of citizens and
lawyers who may be accessing.
it over the internet.
through a firewall.
Give me help.
Some limitations and access also the
presentation layer.
Interact with the business layer, where...
You may be using an SMS client.
The SMS client may be using various
providers, GO, Airtel.
Vodafone.
And.
which interact with external systems,
Airtel system or the Vodafone system,
which is outside.
So they give you gateways, APIs,
through which you can connect with them
and push your messages out.
In fact,
nowadays people use third-party e-mail
services also.
where the emails are pushed through the
secure line and they're sent by the
service provider.
And will that we have various business
models creating a case, scheduling cases.
recording the proceedings,
recording the judgments.
And there's a workflow engine which is
handling this, scheduling the items.
All this data is stored in a database.
The database may be, again,
covered through a firewall.
It may be on a cloud or it may be local.
AHMED.
And it maintains various.
Types of data cases, proceedings,
schedules, users.
and maintains the DB connections.
So this is how a layered architecture may
be distributed.
You have your.
presentation layer which is running on.
Maybe a browser, maybe on a thick client.
In the middle way, you may be having a.
Web server, something like IAS.
Which may be using.
J dcb SQL.
Jay, or you may be using OLED OLED bdb.
Any form of connection might be there to
the database,
and we may have various services running
enterprise, Java beans, web services.
Java servlets, any sort of...
Code that is running over here,
and the IS may be delivering it.
To the browser,
so we will be having various types of
database.
bdb 2 running on.
OS 2 on IBM, you may have Ms. SQL Server,
you can have Oracle.
Could be a no SQL database,
so you have that.
In UTPAL.
So you have the presentation, business,
service layer, and data access layer.
Yeah.
Functional separation of concern.
You can have specialists working on each
of the technology.
People who understand database.
work on the database. You understand?
User interface, user experience,
they work on the...
User interface layer.
We keep the coupling loose.
We don't share.
Details of the functionality between two
layers.
It's a very, very...
rigid, departmentalized functioning,
almost like a government setup,
where you know you pass the paper from
one department to another and you better
not ask what's happening over there.
So, we call this loose coupling in once a.
The request has be passed to the next
year. You are supposed to simply chill.
When it's processed,
you will get your response.
You don't like the response,
you take action then.
But don't tell us what we are supposed to
do. Don't share half the work with us.
Don't do part of it and then try to tell
us you did it incorrectly.
Lower layer components should be reusable.
When we mean reusable is the lower the
layer.
It should be.
The commonalities.
So, you got functionality XY plus exit.
Move X out, y + z.
This X should go into the lower layer,
Y and Z can stay in the upper layer.
So, if there's any...
Type of an activity which can be used.
in more than one way.
That common service should always go
downwards.
Exchangeable parts.
Two or three-layer architecture.
See, I call this is a data access layer,
business layer,
and I call the user interface layer.
Keeping this as it is,
without changing it,
I can simply throw out user interface
layer one and bring in user interface
layer 2.
Simply. I start my development.
The user interface layer one,
people don't even need to know about it.
These interface specifications are shared
with a new team. The new team develops it.
And the first,
the team maintaining user interface one
says, thank you, end of life,
not required, user interface layer 2.
Two takes over.
everybody starts getting the services on
layer two.
The lower layers remain exactly as they
are.
There's a decision to change the database.
To work on the new database,
make sure that every functionality
provided by this is provided by the new
database.
Whatever new you want to do a site,
but whatever exists should get done.
Once you're absolutely ready,
you've done the test, you take a,
say you're doing a blue-green deployment.
For this,
you take a new one and say you have the
blue dal, then you have the green dal.
You try out the user interface layer with
the business access layer with the green
data access layer. It works.
Every type of performance is evaluated.
You've done your regression testing.
Everything is fine.
Functionalities have been confirmed.
One fine date, you simply
migrate the data here and start off on
the new application.
So this is what you call exchangeable
parts. And that's the beauty of it.
If you can divide your...
application into layers,
it becomes possible to replace an entire
layer and pull in a new layer altogether
without changing the other layers.
And what should be a proper division of
layers is what is good architecture,
what is the
Traction protocol between layers is good
architecture.
OK, techniques use.
The videos.
Small niceties about each layers which
one should be aware of.
Use a cache.
See, you have a product catalog.
You've heard about cookies and then they
scare you every time you open a site and
says, this site uses cookies.
You want to use all cookies,
selective cookies, this, that. No.
They're basically taking permission.
will ask you to store certain data
locally.
You've got to understand as an architect
the pros and cons of storing locally
versus storing on the server.
Even on the server,
it can go into the main database or it
can be a cache.
On the server side.
A client-side cache.
is for material which is not likely to
change during the course of your
discourse.
the names of the cities in your state,
the states in India.
The product catalog,
if you're shopping on Amazon,
might go to the database to get the
catalog every time, pull it down,
and maybe you maintain tags,
or you maintain a.
Date stamp.
And if the date stamp,
you have a validity of your date stamp.
Oh, you have certain triggers.
Will you refresh your?
Product catalog.
So, at what frequency do you need to?
Update the product catalog will determine
the usability of the application.
Maybe within a particular search,
you don't refresh.
So this is what we mean by maintaining a
cache.
A cache is basically a copy of the data
maintained to make retrieval quicker.
so that you don't have to do it again and
again.
Bing.
There are techniques available.
Ejects.
So this is a Java access mechanism.
Where?
You have a screen?
SATPRIT, if you just say...
Facade layer is part of server-side
caching.
That's not how we define facade layer.
Facade may handle the caching.
Okay,
that could be a functionality performed
by the facade,
but that is not by definition what facade
is.
So...
See,
I definitely have two of my nieces
working for Amazon.
I can probably find out one of them is
actually working as a senior technical.
Manager on the Amazon retail application,
so,
but I still wouldn't know how often they
refresh the product list in the in a
particular life cycle of its usage.
Say I open Amazon.
Retail over here, and I look up books;
the list of books appear.
I do not know what will trigger.
A refresh of my.
Copy on the screen here,
and I'm not very sure how much of data
they would be maintaining for me on the
server side. Now,
these are decisions which...
People who are involved in an application,
they have a lot of statistics available.
They have the experience of working on
that application. They take a decision.
As far as we can say in a course like
this is that each one of this is a
possibility.
You must be aware of all the
possibilities.
So we will not try to say that this is
the right way. There's nothing right.
For example,
there's an application which I've used
over the last 20 years.
the Canada visa application.
And...
That site was painful 20 years back.
I used to wonder what type of quacks they
had sitting there,
writing the application of them.
Last year I had to renew my visa again
and I found the application very,
very smooth.
So.
Okay.
Even the best of the people in the world.
The only people who can judge the work,
even if they can't do the work,
are the critics. They say, no, the books,
never books written about critics,
but critics definitely know what is wrong.
They don't know how to do the right stuff.
They're good at sensing what is wrong. So,
well,
I'm criticizing this site 20 years back.
I wonder whether I would have been able
to do the same job.
myself and if I had done it,
whether it would have invited more
criticism than the people who did it.
But the reality is that it...
They are definitely maintaining some sort
of a cache.
at the server end because I've tried,
they give me a user ID login and 20 years
back when I used it,
that time they were not.
They're probably keeping an XML file on
my laptop.
And it was getting updated, and...
If I, for some reason,
it could not identify with the previous
thing,
I had to enter the things all over again.
Today, I don't need to.
I could systematically move forward.
And I'm sure after 10 years, when I
get it renewed again,
probably it'll be a final job.
They'll help me pick up some data on
their own. For example,
I don't know which airlines I was booking
the ticket and I didn't have to enter my
name and all that data.
All they'd ask me is open your passport
to the first page.
scanned the first page,
it read the first page,
picked up all the data and filled up all
the places. My name, sex, date of birth,
passport, particulars, everything.
It was all done.
If one airlines could do it,
I'm sure it wouldn't be much time before
all the other airlines learn how to do it.
And many of my students listening to me,
maybe any of you working on an airlines
reservation app?
Anybody out there?
Good.
Okay, nobody is there, but...
Here is, it's a very simple thing,
but I'm sure almost all of you would have
booked an air ticket sometime.
Anybody had the same experience as me
where you just scan the passport and
picked up all the data?
I don't remember the airlines;
that's my only problem,
probably Etihad or something.
Has any?
So everybody sitting in my class just now
has been typing in all the particulars,
passport data and date of birth and all.
You're typing by hand.
He didn't pick it up.
And the one I'm talking about with my
camera screen.
Yeah, do you freely scan the passport?
Yeah, and then they do. That of course,
you know, India has become great now.
Nowadays,
you just walk through immigration.
You don't have to.
You just walk through, you go there,
you show your passport. You're through,
immigration is done. They've got,
they maintain the, yeah,
Digi Yatra is for internal movement. Yes,
if you are on a Digi Yatra,
I first experienced it many years back in
Hyderabad.
And I've had students in my class who've
been working on the Digi Yatra app.
In fact,
they told us about how it worked and how
initially they had less bugs in Android.
There were a few bugs in the iPhone app.
Yeah, cards also, right? Cards. In fact,
many of these mobiles,
when you pick up your data for somebody's
name and address,
the person shows you the card,
you just scan it and it updates the
contact particulars. So
These are good user interface features
which people are building in.
But let's get back to Ajax.
Ajax says that if I have got my screen
here and I've got my server wherever the
database is through the data access layer.
This particular button,
normally the old-fashioned approach on a
web page was the whole web page used to
get refreshed.
And that created a lot of traffic on the
internet.
Now what happens is every button has a
direct connection with a serverlet.
So, if you are typing the name of a city.
It actually...
KHAN.
access another layer and keep refreshing
itself. Now,
that layer might be maintaining a cache.
So it could be getting updated from there.
And maybe it is not that way at all.
It is maintaining a local database and
simply filtering over here.
So, various approaches you can have.
Local data as you type filter to show the
items which come forward.
Go to the.
Business logic page.
through using Ajax technology get updated.
So even Ajax is slow compared to a local
P.
filter. If you have a limited list,
you might like to simply,
or you might download when you have
entered 3 characters after that user
filter. Yep, somebody is saying something.
Okay, that's just an accident. Okay.
So, then...
Once you have data which is cached into
your local machine.
rendering it again and again. For example,
if you're writing an Android app.
The moment you switch from portrait port
to a.
Landscape mode.
It needs to be rendered again.
That rendering can be done from a local
cache.
So, these type of techniques.
The type of responsive design and the
tools which are available for responsive
design these days is absolutely crazy.
VINOD.
Client end catching.
If the data is very frequently used,
you'd like to keep it as a client site.
And hindsight caching can even be done on
cookies. Your personal name, address,
telephone number,
all this type of data may be lying on
your local machine.
And...
Any application required at the moment
you enter your name, it can.
Pick up corresponding fields.
If there are different back-end modules
that require the same data again and
again,
even any good RDBMS maintains caches with
the results of recent queries.
So that queries made thereafter can.
Deliver data quicker if they find that.
There's no need to go down further,
you know, that again, date stamping.
Whether the data is,
if the data in the database is more
recent than what is available in the
cache,
then you go and query in the database.
Otherwise,
deliver the data right from the cache.
In fact,
for certain applications like mail
servers,
you may even use proxies to speed it up
access.
Then.
You can use combinations of server side
and client side carrier.
This I would like to you to read through
carefully on your own.
Memkesh.
Without memcache and with memcache.
So Memcache is a high-performance
distributed memory object caching system,
generic in nature,
but originally intended for use in
speeding up dynamic web applications by
alleviating database load.
So I'll give you
Very nice illustration.
Say you're working using the.
NET framework.
The.
NET Framework can maintain your data set,
data tables, complete objects locally,
and...
Through a single query,
when you've finished doing your
processing,
you can update the entire database and is
maintaining a background connection to it.
So what happens is all the work you're
doing on screen.
Is completely delivered from this.
Object-based database that we maintained
as a part of the.
application. Now,
this could be maintained even in the
business layer and delivered.
at the user interface.
If you are using a thick client
application, when I say thick client,
I mean a non-browser based application
where you load an application into a
Windows machine or an app on a mobile.
These apps have got a certain amount of
business logic inside the app,
the user interface and some amount of
processing logic.
And these apps can handle significant
amount of data caching.
So that's why apps give you a.
far richer user experience than a
browser-based application. Of course,
it's all a question of who's developed
which one and how nicely the web
application has been done.
Even web applications can use.
Object models which can speed up
performances, but by and large.
Some product lists depend on the product
category selected by the user.
So.
These can be asynchronously collected.
So you select a product category,
the full product list under that category
can come up.
Then.
You want to?
Do some validation.
You want to do some quick calculations.
You entered the loan amount,
the number of years.
It should be able to tell you the EMI.
That can be done through Ajax.
You may like to...
Collect.
feedback data in a summarized way using
NEYYALA engine.
you write down the name of the product or
the feature you want.
And the moment you finish typing,
it fetches the data from the background
and gives you a small summary on the
screen without refreshing the entire
screen.
So a chat panel can be displayed on the
site.
This is the architecture of Ajax.
It includes JavaScript.
You have the user interface,
you have the Ajax engine.
on the server side,
your server side logic,
server side system,
and you have the web server or the Ajax
server which handles this interaction.
So this is a pair.
And the user interface.
uses the Ajax engine and keeps updating
the object.
Responsive web design, this is counted.
I wish it would be larger, yeah.
I'm sure.
Mr.
DHIMAN would be having a major problem
with this.
Yeah.
See, depending on this is a mobile.
Under portrait view.
This is a slightly wider, maybe a tablet.
Is the browser screen?
This may be on a TV screen.
So is the same site.
The completely to be rendered differently.
is what responsive design gives you.
So you have these grid, it's a flexi grid.
The flexi grid rearranges and resizes
itself by percentages.
And if it can't handle it,
it just rolls downwards.
So this sort of capability.
HTML5 CS3.
They help out any standard web
development frameworks like Drupal would
be able to handle this with you.
even the latest.
NET frameworks have got the capability of
handling.
this type of responsive design.
Business Leah, user interface components.
Process components,
you have the application logic,
the application facade as a.
Something was mentioning sometime back,
SATPRIT.
So.
Uh...
When you go into software design,
we sometimes consider facade even as an
architectural pattern,
but primarily a design pattern.
There's one class.
which does the interaction on behalf of a
complete set of classes.
We may call this set of classes a package,
and other layers, or...
other modules outside this module will
interact with classes in this module only
through the facade.
So if you have to maintain...
Any caching?
The best candidate for maintaining the
caching would be the facade.
So to that extent,
what SATPRIT has said carries a lot of
weight that.
We use server side caching in the now
facade layer.
Normally we call it a facade class
because if it is a layer,
that means your layer itself has got sub
layers.
And one of them is acting as a facade.
Which means...
The bigger application is probably not a
real application.
So...
Like,
if you are adding a feature and the
feature has got multiple.
layers in it,
the topmost layer becomes a facade which
will provide the services to other
sub-modules. When we work with the...
architecture,
we are talking about subsystems,
the interaction between subsystems.
A particular subsystem itself may have a
different architecture.
After all,
you're having an Oracle database engine,
you're having an Android delivery of the
user interface,
completely different worlds altogether.
People working in Oracle don't need to
know the ANUPAM ABC of what Android is.
And the people working on an Android
application don't need to know anything
about Oracle. Yet,
the architect who's designing a system
using both better know a little bit about
both. And that's why I keep telling you.
Keep your language superficial,
but be very clear on your vocabulary.
You must understand what each of these
terms are, what they do.
What will these people deliver?
Business clear techniques.
Application facade.
which will hide the internal modules.
So, you have the...
User interface layer, business layer.
Business layer has got a facade and then
it is using various modules inside.
So inside.
Now, in this case,
it is not a facade layer.
It is a facade as a class or as a module.
Their support use here, and...
You have various applications that are
being used, so...
The inner application may be a blackboard.
We'll talk about what blackboard
architecture is when we come to design
architectural patterns,
which is after the midterm example.
Session management.
Session management, you know,
we know that the internet is stateless.
So.
Then if you want to be known to the
server, you have to generate a session.
And...
If you may give session a life that if it
is not used for such idiot, it will die,
and...
Everything, the...
So, return something it.
This is a huge 32-bit large.
complex key.
It provides a session ID and provides a
data back.
And even the data which has been
transported against the session may need
to be encrypted because somebody might
eavesdrop into your data.
But session management helps you to
identify.
the actual user of an application who
needs to be returned the information from
the server.
And then you have got workflow engines.
Workflow engines are basically an
application which handles.
The working of various.
application components in certain
sequences based on certain business rules.
ANAND.
By having these designs.
You can have a very modularized design of
your.
business layer which can be easily
modified as required.
Facade. So we talked about facade.
I prefer calling it facade.
Some people call it a facade,
but facade won't be a correct
pronunciation. Let's stick to facade.
The word facade is originally used in the
getup of a building.
We normally call it the front facade and
architects and engineers spend a lot of
time designing the front facade because
There's some iconic buildings.
You see the Reserve Bank of India
anywhere. It's got a.
You get it.
Yeah, yeah,
somebody was going to mention some.
facades which are absolutely outstanding.
OK.
Companies, most of the large IT companies,
they have got fancy.
Front gate facets, you know,
you look at the gate and you covered a
very great so and so company,
whether it's IBM, Capgemini, Cognizant,
Wipro, whatever the company.
TCS.
They all have a very smart front facade.
That is,
and the role is not only the get up. Yes,
but it is the get up. After all,
you put up a smart look when you go for
an interview. If you have a turban,
you tie it as well as you can.
You'll do up your
Hair proper grooming,
you'll probably have a shave,
or if you have your hair flying,
you'll probably have it set, and...
Very proper test.
Okay, yeah, Abash.
Yeah, I would like you to say hello.
YAWAR.
Good morning, sir. Good morning.
Yeah, hi, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I'm going to explain this coupling and
cohesion, because absolutely fundamental,
this is a very,
very important principle in software
itself, forget architecture.
Oh.
Maybe it's a private question,
but I don't know. In India,
we go around asking these questions.
Are you married or are you single?
No, I'm married.
married.
Would your spouse like it and would you
like it if you are breathing down each
other's neck all the time?
Every time she wants to do something,
you have to stand by her.
No.
That is excessive coupling.
None.
You're a couple,
but you just can't be tied together all
the time.
But,
and how is it possible if there's
OK.
cohesion in your capabilities?
What you can do,
you know how to do it alone.
What she can do,
she knows how to do it alone.
You meet up for dinner,
but if you are cooking two items,
she cooks what she cooks,
you cook what you cook,
you bring it together for dinner.
That's the best way it gets cooked
properly.
So,
cohesion is the capability of any module.
Okay, got it.
or any class or any subsystem to be able
to handle what it is supposed to handle
independently without use of anything
outside. If it is required,
the capability has got to be developed
within. Okay.
Coupling is coupling should always be
loose, but you require coupling,
otherwise you can't work together;
you are not a couple at all.
But excessive coupling is bad.
Cohesion should not result in duplication.
You learn the same stuff.
She goes and learns the same stuff.
It is a duplication.
So if say there are some,
you both work in the kitchen and you got
a mixing, you share the mixing.
The mixie should not be your personal
property or her personal property.
It's a common item.
So it's an external system.
That's a service. OK.
So I think that should clarify cohesion
and coupling. So what is good?
Low coupling, high cohesion is good.
And they go.
JSON response. JSON response. GURURAJ,
you need to explain it here.
What exactly?
Now, when, when,
when defining communication between
components, right, normally what we do,
each component should...
The response in JSON format,
so that helps individual model score.
Let me put JSON in perspective for other
people in the class.
Many people here may not be aware of JSON.
JSON is a communication methodology
whereby 2 objects can pass data to each
other in a flat format.
It's a text type format,
which means a notepad format,
but it is highly indexed. It has got tags,
and it is structured as per the object
design on both sides.
Both these objects interact with each
other. So if you are saying that, yes,
they keep the coupling low,
by doing all the work here and doing
whatever work is to be at the other end
and they communicate very neatly using a
JSON. Is that what you mean?
Yes, yes, that's one.
OK, yeah,
so what happens is that a JSON can be
used to keep the coupling low, and...
Typically,
say if you are playing a video game and
you've got, you're shooting me,
I'm shooting you sort of a thing in the
video game,
and both of us have got the object
representing the player X and player Y.
With player X, player Y,
the exact state of each player is
communicated from one to the other.
And my machine is fully capable of
rendering X&Y. I can render X,
I know how to render Y.
But the complete object detail needs to
be communicated there.
And JSON is a nice way to do it.
Of course,
not necessarily that you use JSON.
You can use similar formats.
But the object state has to be conveyed.
Typically,
when you are working in a B2B type of
environment where data is generated in
one location and passed on to another,
Then you create it in a JSON format and
pass it to the other end.
So you stay isolated from each other,
yet there's a complete communication of
data. Actually,
there's no end to the depth we can get
into, but I don't want to scare people.
There are lots of people here with one
year, two years into the line,
they may not be fully aware of these
things.
But you know,
it's good to hear these things.
And whatever you can remember is good.
And we really don't, see,
we are forced to go into detail when
people are discussing case studies and
examples. And yet,
I want to tell you that you don't have to
understand it even at the depth at which
we are discussing in the class.
So I think it's time for a break.
Let's take a 10 minutes break and we'll
continue after the break. Okay.
Yep.
Welcome back.
Various features.
No.
This is basically.
A diagram of flight booking app.
I'm just going to show you a few pages
without going into details.
Concept of session management,
where the browser's identity is being.
Maintain from one request to the next.
So that the...
So, we can maintain a model.
Enterprise Java beans,
stateless and stateful session beans.
So there is a session from the next
station is known, not known.
The concept of a workflow engine,
we set a sequence of...
Work that is done,
which can be done by a separate module.
Then we talk about aspect-oriented design
for cross-cutting concerns.
And these aspects are logging and
instrumentation, auditing, caching,
security, so...
Invidious.
Components of the application in various.
Ohh.
places, the same thing could be required.
So.
Here you are.
These are cross-cutting concerns.
They are used by all the layers.
Let's take for example, some of you again,
it's not that everybody used it,
but definitely some of you would have
used something called Log4j.
Anybody who's willing to share an
experience of Log4j.
Yeah, Guru Raj, let's hear you out.
Just tell us something about your usage
of Log4G. It's a cross cutting concern.
It can be used in all modules. Yeah.
Oh, actually.
Yeah, actually,
I was into production support during that
Me.
time,
so all the application components were
logging into Log4j,
and as a monitoring team,
so we used to monitor the logs of all the
applications in one, you know, Log4j.
portal or something like that.
Now, Guru RAJ, Guru RAJ, just a minute,
just a minute, Guru RAJ.
Java,
it's a Java application's normally logged,
yeah.
You're talking at your level.
Just assume that there are people sitting
here who've got one year's exposure after
BTEC.
Could you just relate your case study at
their level?
Tell them what Log4j is.
Tell them it's an open source tool,
Yeah, I couldn't.
what it does.
And then if you can just explain one year,
Mm.
one year experience after BTech, freshers.
Okay, at that level,
if you can just explain Log4j, yeah.
Yeah, sorry, sir, but...
Yeah,
I don't have much exposure into that as a
developer site. So I was, as I mentioned,
I was into production support as I have
Yeah, you just, just, just the outline.
heard of it and I have used it as an end
user.
Yeah. Okay. Let's put it. In fact,
he has given an absolutely complete
description. I've understood it very well.
Abhinav might be able to throw some
further. Abhinav, Vin, Thinjay,
both are there. Let's hear Abhinav first.
Yeah, I said, so Log4j is again,
it's a framework,
Yeah, hi.
it's it is basically we have worked with
Java,
might know it's a JAGIR file that we put
it into our application, and you know,
for if you want to track how our
application is, you know, executing right,
so every action that is being done of
importance.
gets logged in a log file that at this
time this happened,
at this time this particular thing
happened, this call was made,
this call failed. So that for any,
you know,
if you want to debug any issues later,
the support engineer or anyone can go to
and, you know,
search within their log files to
understand what happened at that.
Superb.
Right, so that is basically what it is.
Yeah, okay. Thanks, Abhinav.
I think I'll have to address Balak.
Balakrishna,
are you a non-CS background or are you
talking for the benefit of others?
Hello, Bala.
You are non-C.S. background,
or you're looking for others,
Yeah, yeah, I am, I'm Nancy,
Nancy has background, so...
or you are OK?
Well, I'm so happy. I'm so happy.
Let me try to interact with you.
See what happens is,
but you've got some exposure to
programming.
Very, I mean.
Little bit, little bit,
one program in your lifetime, hello world.
Yeah, yeah, so during the education,
actually.
In some language? Okay, great. Yeah, yeah,
good, great, great.
That's more than enough.
Now what happens is if you want to use
Yeah, so.
any frameworks or any ready-made code,
you include them in the beginning of your
program. You say include so and so,
and there's certain facilities become
available inside your program. Okay,
that you would have seen.
There's some things you write on the top.
Import or include beginning of your code.
Yes, sir. Yeah, correct, correct, correct.
Now, Log4j is open source. OK,
the moment you write Log4j on top.
Okay.
it becomes available within your
application. And what you do is,
Understood, header,
it's a kind of header file.
within your application, yeah,
now what you do is, as you are processing,
there's certain data you want to save so
that you can use it later on to diagnose
as to what was happening inside the
stomach of your application.
Stomach is closed.
When the program is running,
you don't know what's happening inside.
But you want to record it so that if
there are problems later on,
you can see through that and find how the
data was moving inside your application.
Okay.
You can switch on and switch off those
features with if commands, if debug,
so and so. You may set feature flags.
These are called feature flags.
Now, if you inside the application,
if you use a particular command which is
supported by Log4j, the...
the log maintained by Log4j,
which can be maintaining logs for various
applications and various parts of
applications together in one place.
And you can go into the panel and look up
all the data of a particular type,
and you can set tags in such a way so
that you recognize that this data belongs
to so and so application, so and so.
A program and so and so variable, OK?
So isn't it a beautiful feature?
You don't have to code into it.
Yes, sir. Yes, yeah.
You just use a generalized framework.
When they say framework,
it means a huge bundle of code,
which has its own architecture,
Yeah.
which has its own patterns and all,
to make such a thing happen very
efficiently. Okay, that's the framework.
Can I say library?
It's more than a library.
Library is 1 dimensional.
Okay, understood. Yeah.
Framework is multi-dimensional.
Like I like one example I like to give
Okay.
over framework is the.NET framework.
You can do hardly anything in Windows
without the.NET framework.
Windows itself uses.NET framework to work.
Okay. It's called the.NET framework.
Yes, sir. Thank you. Yeah, thank you, sir.
Yeah,
Okay, super, super. Yeah, so.
it might it might be very basic for
others, but it's something new for me.
Very great, great. Then you must speak up.
It's great. In fact,
Rizal Chowdary has got some exposure,
but I think we'll leave it out for now.
Okay, yeah.
Shisha mentioned that you can set
priorities also.
Shisha,
I would like to hear about this priority.
Let's share it with the group.
Okay, not getting understood.
Yeah, hello sir, hello everyone.
Yeah, yeah, come along, yeah, yeah.
So usually what happens is when we are
building an application,
there might be error where the
application is not able to connect to the
database.
There might also be an error where,
or a problem where the application is,
it's just that one of the dropdown fields
could not be populated.
So there are different levels of issues.
And sometimes you just want to have a
debug workflow. So you want to say,
I love you.
you have set of statements to be logged
as part of a debug flow. So in Log4J,
we can set all those types.
So you can prioritize what needs to be,
what you want to be logged as well,
so that when somebody is looking at it,
They are not just looking at some, yeah,
yeah,
They can set filters,
they can set filters on priority.
set filters and then they can prioritize
saying, you know what,
people are not able to log into the
system. That's a priority one.
No.
So we can set that while coding so
somebody can look it up.
Right.
Whoever is debugging or who is trying to
troubleshoot, it'll be easy for them.
Thank you, sir.
Right.
And there are certain levels that will be
looked up regularly by the support team.
True.
True. No, thanks a lot. That's great.
We have experienced people here,
and I'm telling you,
you will enjoy interacting with each
other. Only thing is,
I keep warning people,
your maturity of interaction will be very
important when it comes to the group.
You cannot tear into each other.
You will have to politely get across.
Because over here,
nobody is reporting to you and you are
not reporting to anybody.
It's a level playing field.
You are classmates.
One of you may be having 25,
30 years experience.
Another one may be having one year.
But here, you are classmates.
Maintain your language.
And during the interaction with me,
I find the language is absolutely
like a lady or like a gentleman,
but when you're on your own in that group
of 25 after assignment two,
you will be evaluated by the tone of your
communication. And again, let me warn you,
it should not be plastic because...
People who experience and...
the faculty member or members who will be
evaluating you.
I extremely experienced people.
When they see plastic conversation,
it doesn't do good for you.
And forget the marks.
Your peer group will also come to know.
Your peer group is bombarded with content
generated by...
AI tools.
Even it's unfortunate that many of our
chat platforms,
they're getting bombarded with generated
images and text. So in that discussion,
try to keep it at a level like...
The way we just had an interaction with
Abhinav, Guru Raj, Balakrishnan,
a very clean, neat explanation. Okay,
this is what happens.
This is what I understand. Fine.
You don't have to be an expert.
So this is the extent to which I've
understood this architecture.
This is what I thought.
This was my interpretation. Okay.
If somebody knows a thing better,
they might throw some light.
You learn a of it. There's no problem.
So we don't.
The idea of having the assignment is not
to try to find out who has got a better
command on the subject,
who can work in an environment better.
and how much you can learn from other
people's working.
That's the type of thing we look for.
Okay. Logging and instrumentation,
business layer, facade,
session management, workflow engines,
aspect-oriented design, data layer,
prominent techniques, connection pooling.
I get tempted to get into these,
but you have to keep the number of
connections to a minimum. In fact,
sometimes we use a singleton pattern,
again, a design pattern,
which makes sure you don't unnecessarily
create multiple connections.
If the connection already exists,
the same connection is used.
Then concept of multiple copy of data,
particularly for read.
You have multiple database for read to
control the traffic.
transaction to achieve atomicity.
You have atomicity is again is a database
concept where all or nothing is recorded.
Object relationship mapping,
where you have objects,
they have a relationship with one another,
just almost like an ear diagram in a
database,
even though objects are related to each
other.
Using stored procedures,
stored procedures is code written in the
database, and there,
that's the fastest way to.
run a compute or any data in a database
is to use two procedures.
Parameterize SQL queries. Again,
Parakrish will stop me if you need to.
When you ask someone a question.
You set certain values.
Oh.
What is the square of a number is a query.
The parameters, the number is 3.
The result is now 9.
You can use the same query with various
parameters, two, three, 4, 5.
You keep getting different results.
If you, in a database,
there is a query language.
Query language is a programming language
which can be executed to get results.
But this query language has got a
limitation.
The limitation is that if it is allowed.
At the UI level.
You can inject malicious code as a
variable.
Instead of giving the value of a variable,
you give the value of the variable and
add to it a certain amount of malicious
code.
And I'm not going to the details of how
to add malicious code.
If you're interested,
you just look up SQL injection.
Just.
Yeah, this will be able to figure out, so.
..
With that malicious code,
you can even go and delete database,
D.
data table, drop a table.
Dangerous things can happen.
But if you take parameters,
then you call a procedure by passing
parameters.
This malicious code cannot get passed
through a parameter.
So these are going into a little bit of
detail,
but the various techniques and each layer
has got techniques which are unique to
the layer.
So.
These are various things, service layers,
we talked about services which are common
to others.
So these exercises you can try to do.
Just your self-study exercises.
D.
Okay, SSL, these are security techniques.
I would like you to read about these,
okay? Logging, we've just discussed.
Internet protocol security,
session management.
We've mentioned session management.
You want a little bit of detail,
you can go through it here.
And I want to jump into this component
now for the last few minutes.
And this is what we want to talk about.
In one of my previous sessions,
somebody had asked this question also.
So.
Yavel is shed.
A little bit of information about
techniques available at the database
level,
where you can improve the efficiency of
execution of code,
and just to know that these are unique at
every.
Area every layer uses its own.
expertise, own tools, own techniques.
Different people may be aware of
different tools and techniques. Now,
let's talk about architecture.
Trade-off analysis method.
Not each word, architecture.
is the way we have our subsystems
interacting with each other and
supporting each other. Trade-off means.
You can't have it all.
And have what? What is that it all?
It is the qualities.
Sir, I have a question here.
The yeah.
So,
regarding the slides that we were
discussing, I think there was,
I can see that we,
Yeah.
is there anything that we skipped or is
there anything for us to do? So,
I think there are like a.
Those exercises are just,
they are just your self-study exercises
for you to spend some time outside and
try to look at that sort of stuff.
Yeah.
There's no evaluation component involved
there. It is just for your own working.
No,
I think the concepts like SSL and then
Yeah, SSL role, you need to,
you basically,
log.
you got to have an idea of what SSL is,
what Log4j is.
Each of these concepts you should be
broadly aware of. You will not have,
IP cec.
beg your pardon?
I, I.P. cec was also there,
and I have this internet security
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, so just just an awareness,
because this is a little bit of jargon
protocol.
that you should know what it is about.
You will not be asked in examination and
implementation of any of these,
not even log4j.
We've discussed it just to make the class
interesting,
No problem, so just it's just a concept.
OK, go ahead.
just to make the class interesting.
Yeah, just as a concept,
you should know this concept is then what
it achieves. Okay, and end result. Okay.
And I have to jump through that.
I would have spent, see,
I should.
these courses are such as architecture,
such a course that any one lecture can be
a one semester course.
So in the examination,
we try to make sure that we try to keep
the level low.
Yet some people do get foxed.
We can't help it.
But if you have a general awareness,
you can more or less approach the paper.
You have to,
what is most important is keep a cool
head and try to build up a vocabulary,
try to
All the words that you come across in
these slides,
at least do the meaning of the words so
that you can,
you don't get completely bold out center
wicket.
Like somebody says Log4j and you are
suddenly talking about database engines
or something like that.
That should not happen.
You should know that Log4j is meant for
logging.
One, sir.
Okay,
and so that level of knowledge should
exist.
You should know SSL is a secure socket
layer. So there's some security involved,
there's some encryption involved.
That much you should be aware of.
It's a security technique.
You should definitely know what memcache
is.
It is a means of maintaining a cache.
So you should know what a session is.
You should know what stateless is.
At that level,
All itself, all it.
you should have a knowledge.
But when we take a class naturally,
you know,
we have to talk about it in a little bit
of case discussion,
a little bit of how it pans out. Okay.
Chill. Yeah.
Now, the thing is, like, one last,
but maybe it will be the interest of
everyone. The thing is, like,
when we fill in the what,
Yeah.
what type of questions we will expect?
Will there be a direct question or a
scenario will be given to us and to
explain? I mean, just, just...
See,
the teachers will always try to give you
a scenario, but in the midterm exam,
in the midterm exam, technically,
Mmh.
Okay.
there can be a direct question.
Got it. So they got it.
Like, what is architecture?
What is the attempt? Yes,
this is a fair question.
Because it's a closed book exam.
What are the steps in attempt?
Understood.
Fair question.
But normally teachers avoid it. Okay.
They try to roll the same stuff into a
small anecdote or try to give you
something small.
But in the comprehensive exam,
Completely application oriented,
totally a different example. OK, yeah.
Thank you. Thank you, sir.
And I think in the previous semester
experience, like, you know,
some professors where, you know,
Yeah.
they were sharing us that how the answer
should be, whether,
whatever the question it is,
whether it is direct.
That is something, yeah, something.
I will tell you one thing.
You give me a question.
I will go to Gemini.
I'll get you an answer and share it with
you.
I don't know why you need a faculty to do
it for you.
Okay.
You know,
the thing is that some professors,
Yeah, some professors do it.
some professors say that the answers
should be big enough.
Big answer should be for a question.
No, no, no, no.
I'm not checking the paper myself,
but I'm absolutely not an advocate of big
answers or small answers.
But look at it this way.
If it is a 90 minutes paper and it's for
30 marks,
You should give 3 minutes for Mark.
Mhm.
Which includes a thinking time.
Okay,
so if it's a five marks question and you
are giving it 15 minutes,
think for 5 minutes, write in 10 minutes.
But what is most important is focus on
the question.
Read each word of the question very
carefully. Don't
be shooting in a wrong direction.
That is the most important part about,
at least in this course. You know,
when people don't know anything,
they start writing anything that enters
their brain.
That's something you've got to be careful
about. Read the question very,
very carefully,
because definitely I monitor the
evaluation. I don't evaluate myself,
but I definitely monitor,
I interact with the faculty.
Two of the people who have been
evaluating with me.
Each one has got about 30,
35 years experience and they've been in a
senior position in IT companies. Okay.
Okay.
whatever best you can,
but don't try to get into the examination
oriented. And if you want sample answers,
because the sample answers generated by
us also are from Gemini.
Let me tell you that.
In fact, it's not Gemini.
We have a portal in BITS for which
generates a question data question bank
and it is AI based.
So these questions and answers are
generated by an AI portal.
The evaluation matrix is also generated
by AI. So.
There's nothing much that a faculty can
hide from you.
You can generate it yourself. Okay.
And do generate.
My suggestion to students,
even my own family members who have
appeared at BITS, I always tell them,
take the slides, put them into Gemini,
tell Gemini to give you some sample
questions.
You can try it out and then tell Gemini,
please give me the sample answers.
Read through them.
Okay.
Thank you very much, Sir.
Thank you very much.
And then, yeah,
and tell tell Gemini that these are
typically 5 Mars questions,
so please give me,
and remember one thing: the questions
will be distributed over the syllabus,
so if the eight CSS.
So let's say that it divided into four
parts. So one, two, three, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So if you divide it into four parts,
7 to 8 marks from every set of two
contact sessions.
Okay.
So, take it that way,
the people will be fairly distributed.
So, you, if you skip set 2 CSS,
you'll be able to attempt to leave 3/4 of
the paper.
Typically.
And these are standard papers generated
by people who've been involved with BITS
for a long time. And my involvement,
as I told you,
with BITS since 1973 continues without a
break. I started as a student.
I immediately after passing out,
I got involved with the academic programs.
And after six years since I was in
corporate jobs,
I could not be involved directly with
BITS.
But then I started teaching in BITS for
these work integrated programs since 1985.
So you can calculate 1985.
It's quite a long time. Yeah, I think.
It comes to some 40 years or so.
This is absolutely standard bits for you.
The people may be having different
approaches. Okay,
so let's now quickly jam through this
attempt. So when we say attempt,
it is trade-off.
So trade-off between what?
Between quality attributes, performance,
security. Oh, big trade-off required.
If I lock the room.
Well,
getting anything from the room is going
to take more time. Performance.
If I try to go in for a lot of
performance.
I might have a problem with testability.
Then.
I want high availability.
It might come at the...
Post off you again on performance or.
If I'm talking about interoperability.
Usability, interoperability,
maybe there's a set of usability,
modifiability, maybe having a set of.
testability, vis-a-vis security,
testability, vis-a-vis performance.
So any of these quality attributes,
then there's a limitation of budget.
I know that for this application,
I've got a budget of 80 lakhs.
No, it relax.
What?
People am I going to employ?
What type of resources am I going to
deploy on this project? Then itself,
I'll have a limitation.
If I spend too much on the user interface,
I don't have money left by to handle the
business layers, the data layers.
Where do I spend on technology?
Where do I spend on manpower?
Which components do I use open source?
Which open source dependable?
Which open source app is sustainable?
It shouldn't happen that five years into
running the application that open source
is unsupported and it becomes vulnerable.
So these are the sort of things that we
talk about.
So I'll have to rush through,
but I'll still cover it.
So you need to evaluate the design.
Then.
The peer group should evaluate it and if
necessarily the outsiders.
So self-evaluation, peer group evaluation,
outside evaluation,
each has got its pros and cons.
Why do you need to evaluate?
Because you need to take a relook.
You need to see.
with what all is being attended to.
If you claim that you are handling
performance,
does it seem that you are handling it?
So, the designers evaluation.
The peer group evaluation.
With the peer group evaluates,
what are the steps?
The review will determine.
What quality attributes are we interested?
The architect presents the quality
attributes and says that this is what I
try to do.
and walks through the peer that this is
what I try to do.
The peer will probably argue with them
and tell him, see,
do you have evidence of this?
Have you tried it out?
Have you seen it anywhere?
It appears you might have so and so
problem. Have where have you seen it?
So you explain I saw it and so and so. No,
it's not exactly the same.
So you have an open discussion with your
peers and if you have.
a very supportive peer,
they will be honest with you and tell you
what the problems are. And then now,
outsiders can be absolutely neutral.
Sometimes an architecture designed by one
company,
the client will give it to another
company to review.
Same, you're doing something.
No,
Pierre decision can be sometimes biased
as well, right?
Peer can be biased, yes,
peer can be biased. Definitely,
Yes.
something that can be unintentional bias.
You know, you are working under the helo,
you have an impression on certain
architects.
Okay.
Everything that fellow says sounds good
to you. So that could be one thing.
Then people as a peer,
They ignore the same stuff.
All of them don't take note of something.
They assume that this is the way things
are done.
An outsider sees it totally differently.
So for example,
if you're doing work for the Air Force,
say, a very secure setup, after you've...
deliver your design,
they give it to a completely different
company. They say, okay,
this is a design you've got, look at it.
Now those people have been paid to break
the design.
So they will try to find out problems and
that's good for the Air Force,
because they'd rather get the design
skills than get the pilot skilled. So
This side type of an outsider can be a
good way to evaluate.
It's a more expensive approach,
more time taking.
Then.
What artifacts are available?
What details is the design?
Is A prototype available?
Are the diagrams available?
Which views are available?
Then your evaluation will depend on.
how the result will be evaluated,
who will see it.
How is that?
How are you going to evaluate individual
commitments that you say that this is
what is going to deliver?
What type of,
if you know it's going to be evaluated,
you'll probably have to substantiate it
with literature experience.
Now, when you evaluate an architecture,
you have to decide who are the people who
should get into evaluation.
Sometimes you do an evaluation of
architecture by stakeholders themselves.
So in which case,
we present the business goals.
We tell the stakeholders that this is
what we intend to achieve.
This is how we are intending to achieve
it. What, according to you,
is important in this application.
So, the first stage is...
You decide the participants.
You have an evaluation team which will
normally have a lead,
which will have scribes,
which will have a person who's capable of
drawing out the scenarios.
You sometimes inject some people who are
brainstormers.
There are people who just will throw in
problems.
The management makes sure that there is
one person who's there who's just
supposed to create a noise or bring up
problems to stoke. You know,
in the coal engine, you have a stoker.
You have a piece of iron which will hit
the coal so that the coal burns better.
So these people are stokers, you know.
They will just inject discussion because
normally in a meeting, everybody is quiet,
everybody listen, must be all right.
But when these stokers,
they create a discussion,
the discussion takes off.
Besides the experts,
you have stakeholders.
Stakeholders are people who invested in
the project,
the people who will handle the legal
aspects of the project.
That means there may be regulations by
the government, by trade bodies,
by international agreements, which
cannot be circumvented.
Like if you are doing something with the
shares,
CCMBAINAI will have its own regulations.
So if it is medical HIPAA,
so you have to conform to these
regulations. And within the company,
the people will be actually using the
application, will use the user interface.
the people who are responsible for
getting results for the business,
people who are committed to market share,
people who are committed to getting
better profits or better employee morale
by using this application.
or employee morale, maybe a HR department,
marketing,
who's interested in getting value out of
the product by placing it in the market.
All these people are important
stakeholders.
So when you get all these stakeholders
together,
There are various roles.
I told you question as a person who
stokes, proceeding Skype,
who writes down what was their scenario
Skype, a person who can draw the scenario,
help individual stakeholders to present
their point of view through a scenario.
That means what is the
stimulus, why, what we need to attend to,
on what artifact,
what are the results you expect,
how do you expect to measure it?
So help the user present it,
because users cannot be very good in
presenting. They know what they want,
but the scenario scribe will help the
users to put it into a proper picture,
people like you.
who are ready for the exam on how to draw
a scenario.
You will help these people to write it
out. Evaluation lead, team lead.
Team lead is a person who can get
everybody together,
people who listen to him.
He can maintain order in the setup,
who will invite everybody to be involved.
Evaluation lead is the...
person who understands architecture very
well. So team lead and architecture lead,
evaluation lead may be the same,
may not be the same also.
So.
At the end of it,
you should be able to present an
architecture.
Everybody should be very clear about what
the business goals are and the connect of
the business goals with what you intend
to do.
So, when you...
Connect the business goals of what you
intend to do.
You'll end up prioritizing the quality
attributes,
which you are doing in assignment one.
You are writing down what are the
scenarios which are most important to you.
Risk and non-risk.
You've got to understand.
All the risks,
risks is like this: you decide to appear
for the makeup rather than take the
regular exam.
The advantage is that you appear for two
exams here, 2 exams there.
Makes very good sense.
What is the risk involved?
Say I fall sick on the day of the makeup,
there's no makeup for makeup.
So there's a cost and there's a benefit.
The benefit is you're going to be able to
study better for two exams.
The risk you're taking is you're gambling
on your health.
You know you've got robust health,
you're not forensic for the last five
years. Even when you're sick,
you normally take crucin and go to office.
Okay, I'll take the risk. So
This is the same thing an architect does.
An architect takes calculated risks.
But these risks have got to be shared
with the stakeholders. See,
this is the risk we are taking.
This is the money we save on the risk.
This is what we are going to achieve
because of the risk.
And the risk should be documented.
So, all the risk themes should be put up,
then the decisions you take,
the decisions could be.
The managerial points which we have
studied in our various things,
how we go around handling a situation and
which scenario we need to attend to.
Then we need to understand the
sensitivity of, what is a sensitivity?
Sensitivity is...
This is input.
This is Outlook.
With a small change in input.
Major change in output is high
sensitivity.
With a large change in input,
low change in output is low sensitivity.
So you've got to understand that in this
quality attribute,
by putting in a little more effort,
you're going to get a huge boost in
performance.
So these sensitivities have got to be
explained to the stakeholders.
Then the stakeholders may decide, okay,
rather than try to spend so much money on
this quality attribute,
if we can compensate by being very strong
somewhere else,
rather than waste so much money and not
achieve much, we will be better off.
So your stakeholders got to be educated.
They are not technical people.
They don't understand.
How many translates into results? So,
the sensitivities have to be identified
and explained.
Intangible outputs have to be taken into
account.
These are the phases of ATM,
which are the various stages,
report generation, delivery.
So these are the steps in detail.
And at a certain stage,
we generate the utility tree,
which you will have all done for your
assignment one.
So you understand what a utility tree is.
You analyze the approach, the risk,
the sensitivities, the trade-offs.
The risk, the sensitivities,
and the trade-offs.
I've explained all three to you. Risk,
I've given you a personal example.
Even in an architecture,
there could be a risk involved based on
the type of technology you're using.
You use something very new. The risk is...
It has not been fully debugged.
But you want to take the risk because the
benefits are enormous.
So, sensitivity we have taken, trade-offs,
taken.
This is an example of an analysis,
how you can tabulate everything.
Brainstorming and prioritization.
Again, we have reached the end of time,
but you can read through it very clear.
We have discussed prioritization and
brainstorming on an earlier occasion in a
different context.
Then you present the results.
Lightweight is a shortcut approach to
attempt. So same thing, it will repeat,
but you finish it off in four to six
hours. And with that, we complete.
The time is 10.20,
and last time I had exceeded the time.
So we are closing on time.
See you next week. And
All the best with finishing our
assignment.
Try to finish it today or tomorrow.
Don't keep it for the last day.
Very dangerous. Okay. Bye bye.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, thank you, thank you. Great,
great, grateful. Had a nice time.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Seven.
And I hope you enjoyed it too. Bye.